hi my name is Brian favor and I am the
brew master of operations or shoots
brewery we know financially we need to
be able to take on this investment to
build a second brain production facility
is a big undertaking a big financial
investment so it's very important that
we're able to really maximize our
capacity and efficiencies and so that's
when we reached out to go si soft
here at si soft we really believe that
if we can get your process data your a
sensor based data to you at your
fingertips you can transform how you
operate your business you can solve
problems that just wouldn't be capable
without data we're making decisions on
now multiple decisions on an hourly
basis on how to run our operations so if
we don't have the data the back that
have them supported it leads us
definitely in a bind
basically a security failure is not an
option for us I've been fortunate to be
part at Microsoft Research of a
revolution and security testing has
taken place for the last 15 years for
the first time they have the ability to
access a cloud that gives them 20 times
a scale they could get on their own
doesn't require any special security
knowledge to use it has the very best
combination of methods that we know and
they we are always improving it we use
the phrase million dollar bug to signify
that security bugs are serious they're
important they're worth investing to
prevent everyone wants a way of solving
this problem during a development of
Windows 8 we asked 3.4 billion questions
to the constraint solver that we have
here at Microsoft and 90% of them were
answered in a tenth of a second Project
Springfield has really allowed us to
test our product and new ways that we
haven't been able to before given the
new technology for Microsoft we'd give a
job to Springfield we'd get the bug
report we do our actions based on
whatever the report would tell us and
then we'd resubmit the job again and
hopefully get 0 having a project like
Springfield to assure that our data
systems are going to be up and reliable
and available to us 100% of the time is
critical for us to be successful